in Glasgow Scotland a professional chef
named Michael wakes up with a woman
sleeping beside him yay does it seems
like the two recently got intimate and
are trying to sleep surprisingly Michael
kindly asks the girl to leave mentioning
that he finds it hard to sleep with
someone else in his bed initially the
girl laughs it off thinking that Michael
must be joking but when he keeps
insisting she angrily gets out of the
bed and leaves meanwhile Susan an
epidemiologist can be seen taking a walk
on the beach with her sister Jenny turns
out she recently went through a breakup
and is having a hard time coping with it
to relieve her stress she starts
throwing rocks at
goddamn shithax in the next scene
Michael arrives at the restaurant where
he works and has a typical day serving
many customers and making varieties of
dishes his co-workers tease him for
ending yet another short-lived
relationship and dumping a girl just
after being romantic on the other hand
Susan returns to work after being absent
since her breakup unexpectedly her boss
Steven interrupts her on her way to the
lab and takes her to the hospital
explaining they need her there at the
hospital they encounter a man with a
puzzling condition sudden depression and
excessive crying followed by a loss of
smell Susan wonders why she was called
for such a strange case and Stephen
informs her that similar cases have been
reported worldwide in the past 24 hours
with no apparent connections between the
patients they decide not to panic for
now hoping the situation will resolve on
its own the next day Susan is smoking by
the window before work when she spots
Michael coming out of the restaurant's
back door on her street they notice each
other and Michael playfully asks Susan
for a cigarette hey babe you got some
cans answer for me she tosses one to him
and Michael playfully asks her to visit
the restaurant as he is a chef there
however to his dismay Susan ignores him
and closes her window later at the lab
Susan and her co-worker update Stephen
with their findings they've ruled out a
virus and contagion but they acknowledge
that the problem is spreading they also
discussed that the possible causes could
be a new toxin environmental factors or
even terrorism they agree that it's
definitely spreading as more and more
people in the city experience sudden
bouts of grief during the day followed
by a loss of smell just sounds like
they've all been to Taco Bell to me
meanwhile the authorities addressed the
issue on the news assuring people that
scientists are investigating the
situation and there's no need to panic
however despite their stressing that
it's not contagious fear grips the
streets people start going out less and
those who do wear masks to protect
themselves one evening Michael's
Restaurant is empty so the staff leaves
early later when Michael also goes
outside to smoke he sees Susan arriving
after work he chats her with her for a
while before inviting her for dinner at
the restaurant where there's extra food
due to the lack of customers initially
Susan hesitates which makes sense given
she's in charge of the outbreak but she
eventually joins after some insisting
because she's a inside Michael
presents her with his special dish and
Susan appears to be greatly impressed by
his cooking skills however while
enjoying the meal she is suddenly
overwhelmed with grief and starts crying
she mentions that she remembered her
late father and cannot stop thinking
about him Michael Comforts her and
offers to take her home disregarding her
concern about catching the mysterious
illness he stays to comfort her until
she falls asleep but ends up
experiencing the same grief himself now
both of them console each other and
eventually fall asleep the following
morning Michael wakes up to greet Susan
in the kitchen and gets to know that she
has lost her sense of smell right then
he also takes a sip of tea and realizes
that he can't smell either or maybe that
he is just silly British poo water and
is weak as they adjust to their new
reality Susan finds her work with
animals easier without the smell spot at
Michael's Restaurant they face
challenges due to the loss of Aroma in
cooking his co-workers then decide to
intensify the flavors in food with more
spices and condiments to compensate
however they all lament the loss of
memories triggered by scents after some
time Michael arrives at Susan's
apartment and asks her out on a date at
first she shows no interest in his
proposal but eventually agrees to go on
a walk with him during the stroll they
encounter a violinist who uses music and
leaves to evoke the feelings of smells
and the memories they bring this gives
our protagonists a strange type of
Attraction toward one another so without
wasting any time they returned to the
apartment get Randy and spend time
together surprisingly Michael who does
not like anyone sleeping on his bed
falls asleep peacefully but after a
while Susan tells him that she needs to
be all by herself and requests Michael
leave without questioning her choice he
leaves his visiting card and walks out
of her apartment on his way home Michael
encounters a man who sees the loss of
smell as a divine punishment and
believes the end is near can it Trevor
you say that about everything back in
his bed Michael struggles to sleep even
though he's alone feeling the lingering
impact of the day's events the following
day he visits his fiancee's grave at the
cemetery and encounters her parents who
criticize him for not bringing flowers
for their daughter meanwhile Susan
spends time with her sister Jenny and
her kids she learns that her ex is
getting married and having a baby soon
Susan also talks about Michael unsure if
she truly likes him because she tends to
choose the wrong Partners hearing this
Jenny suggests she give Michael a chance
and accept him however Susan replies
that she does not want to fall in love
again and bear the pain of the breakup
as the days pass various theories about
the mysterious illness emerge worldwide
environmental groups suspect an
ecological apocalypse intelligence
agencies think it's an attack on freedom
fundamentalists view it as Divine
punishment and some blame capitalism
considering it an economic scheme there
are even mentions of alien involvement
resulting in people losing their Sen and
eventually their minds one afternoon
Susan witnesses her boss Stephen having
a severe panic and anxiety attack at the
lab she confronts him at the moment but
later experiences the same panic attack
in the parking lot along with her
co-worker and others worldwide these
attacks are followed by intense hunger
leading people to eat strange things
like flowers raw meat lipstick and even
clothing some people are even eating
Tide Pods but that's just because
they're idiots on Tick Tock however when
the frenzy subsides people feel
disgusted by themselves and realize that
they can no longer taste anything in the
midst of coping with these changes Susan
seeks comfort in Michael she explained
that taste and smell are connected and
it's natural for them to disappear
together though she's not sure if their
other senses will be unaffected the next
morning season looks out the window and
sees the people are back on the streets
and their lives are still going on
despite the changes with this motivation
she encourages both herself and Michael
to continue with their routines even
though he's unsure if he'll keep his job
later they agree to start dating as they
believe that soon people will lose other
senses and will need someone by their
side to stay happy in the next scene
when Michael reaches the restaurant his
boss informs him that they won't be
opening due to the lack of clients turns
out people only buy flour and fat these
days because they can't taste or smell
their food however Michael disagrees
with his boss and believes that people
will still enjoy going out for dinner
and celebrating with big toasts he
decides to reinvent the Restaurant's
menu focusing on Textures and sounds and
luckily it becomes a great success
people return back to restaurants
because they enjoy the social experience
of being served and cherish food
together with their dear ones as the
world adapts other Sensations replace
taste and there are more bands playing
music on the streets some people resort
to inhaling laughing gas for
unconventional enjoyment nope that's
called a whippet and dumbasses have been
doing that for decades meanwhile Michael
and Susan spent most of their time
together finding joy in everyday
activities like bathing and shaving they
even playfully taste soap and shaving
cream just for the sake of it during an
evening of dancing drinking and smoking
Susan proposes a game called make me
special she explains that the rules are
simple they have to share secrets no one
else knows about them she goes first and
reveals that she strangely hates her
sister's children because she herself is
infertile oh when it's Michael's turn he
confesses that he ran away from his sick
fiance in the past and wasn't even there
for her at the time of her death because
of this he visits her grave regularly to
cope with the guilt days later the lab
receives a video call from Thailand
where a scientist reveals a new symptom
fits of Rage followed by loss of hearing
he himself demonstrated on the call and
seeing this Stephen decides that it's
time to panic soon people around the
world start getting violent and after
their rage subsides they realize that
they have lost their sense of hearing
but despite all of this people still
find a way to continue with their normal
lives the UFC is going to Boom one day
Susan goes to work and hears important
news a baby was born with all senses
intact offering a potential source of
antibodies meanwhile Michael Learns that
the restaurant is being shut down due to
an infected person on the third floor
the council offers them a job to cook
for the quarantined serving pasta al
dante made from fat and flour
entire Street gets sealed off Michael
waits for Susan and invites her to stay
with him since she can't access her
place Susan agrees but before heading to
Michael's house she pauses to soak in
the sounds of the world one last time
once at Michael's Place Susan playfully
mentions living together but all of a
sudden he changes his demeanor and
reacts negatively he becomes a verbally
abusive insulting her and mentioning her
infertility he then starts throwing
things around the house and keeps
belittling season the situation
escalates into violence and a frightened
Susan finally decides to leave as she
drives through chaotic streets she
notices people shouting for help however
she remains inside her car and drives
away to her lab soon after Susan leaves
Michael's rage outbreak subsides and he
realizes that he has lost his hearing to
make matters worse his house is
quarantined and he receives orders to
stay inside with government provided
noodles no not the noodles not the
noodles later season arrives at the lab
to find Stephen alone and helpless right
then Michael causer apologizing for his
behavior and expressing his love for her
but Susan refuses to answer him back and
throws away her phone some
epidemiologist unfortunately she also
succumbs to rage and becomes deaf
following this she heads to her sister's
apartment as it is the only safe place
in the city for her meanwhile Michael
leaves his quarantined house and visits
Susan's apartment arriving below her
window however she is not there instead
he finds his boss at the restaurant who
has also lost his hearing across the
globe two movements emerge one group who
believes in the impending end of the
world starts running through the streets
and looting everything on site however
the other one is focused on rebuilding
and using sign language as their primary
means of communication they believe that
the world will one day return back to
normalcy some of them even blindfold
their eyes and prepare for their next
loss of sense I.E Vision next Michael's
Restaurant reopens serving dishes
designed for texture and using lights to
Signal new orders he visits a bar they
used to frequent and is surprised to
find people still enjoying live bands by
placing their hands on the speakers to
feel the vibrations that's stupid as the
world awaits the darkness people focus
on visual experiences like reading
getting tattoos and appreciating
paintings and sunsets most spend their
time with their families but Michael
drowns his sorrows in alcohol calling
out Susan's name under her window in the
last scene as Darkness approaches an
emotional symptom emerge joyful Euphoria
people start feeling extreme happiness
and have no regrets jealousy or guilt
they hug each other cherishing life's
Beauty at the same time Michael and
Susan both remember the happiness they
shared and seek each other out Susan
arrives at the restaurant and Michael
rides his bicycle to find her but is
unable to stop her as she drives away
however Susan has to return to a one-way
Road and they finally meet in the middle
of the street both are happy to see each
other after a long time and as they walk
toward each other Darkness engulfs them
this is when we get to know that people
around the globe have turned permanently
blind however the movie ends with
Michael and Susan holding hands sharing
a tearful kiss and embracing their final
moments together looking like any other
couple in deep love subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching